okay guys we are playing a new game
okay so mala crap simulacrum Cibola
people to say some oh crap it's like
simulacra
make a sentence a simulation anyway this
is like the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay my trailer dref 5a vinick's
Newburgh game very addictive Lambie
Bernie yeah
jet injector burn inject the bird into
your brain it's about a very nice oh
okay I get it
tell me what you think Teddy's saying
this to me
Teddy what I lose there that's right
okay this is what happens to you if you
fail you're my friend no my best friend
and I'm flattered I'm pouring my heart
out here tell me what you think it's a
[ __ ] loop I think you need to go back
to the game don't you see it wants you
now
this is what happens to failures I'm
afraid I don't what to drag my friend -
yeah my best friend said it disappoint
ya at the point so this guy is like
pleading he ever got sucked in and now
he's like trying to help me
you need to end this yeah the stairway
I'm done talking to you okay you need to
go back to the game I know you're
listening shut up Jeff just keep playing
and I got anywhere yeah I'm right here
sure joy help me end whoa back to Teddy
hey Jeremiah profile pic he's the ass
kisser
you've been showed up for the interview
and some fancy suit like who are you
trying to impress I think once you're
looking you had a person but being top
student helps to write AB clothes can
exude confidence yeah but if you the
only one dressed like that that's just
awkward and I suffer ranting kind of
nervous wait little jab Oh what the [ __ ]
okay there applied what's my spam yeah
check it good news I need to know what's
going on here
Teddy let's see see how the background
is whoa and it is trippy it's a good
game man oh [ __ ] son of a blogger sloppy
bullet butthole what's it blood holes
like that [ __ ] was that there's this
this is my hope is a painful you
sunshine it'll affect for you three keep
passion candy to over and over again I'm
sure you did you pass bra like yeah you
know what they say grab the Kishin we
just had to go with a better fit yeah
you get it this time okay ground see a
lot of [ __ ] man where's the images no
downloads that's where the good stuff is
one fo just the Irish wallpaper the
Irish game's wallpaper my favorites
Manny's pizza pizza
they have to pick up their pizza place
dude
it's got a lot of battery battery yeah
next time like next time if life I'm
sick of putting myself out there anymore
getting rejected like yesterday dirty
laundry if we're looking more jack [ __ ]
to these guys forget about that bro
Teddy you're fine you're right
we're so bad about this that's what I
wanted something less sad like what I
need your help bro you know what I can
rhyme right now anything rap is not like
weird I need some eggs
mmm Mario gets it bro yeah contacts he's
some currency for a mobile game and this
one I call mags [ __ ] no that's right you
expand your Matt a little more it's a
game called flappy bird I'm so close to
tasting the high scores nice it makes a
save Rhett he was away make me feel good
what I do
sounds like a ripoff bread was last time
clay a truly original game mr. fancy
pants the copy just as good or even
better than the original I condemn it I
spoke of Demerol now this is the only
good thing I have going for me it means
so much to get this one small break and
the best part it's great that you feel
better let's get down on this game Flint
I got a kid of a tip is science uh you
know how my life is at the moment a
bottomless pit of missed misery yeah
that's very true Teddy still at a semi
time relief to mrs. Cameron Eileen off a
little bit
oh yeah I forgot that Shepard chinna lol
Brown well there's me
caffeine daily sky pick a bird some
account killed again but these are worth
it
well there should we say SPL y3 - I want
a physical [ __ ] coat later on I can
flap a check out this on game or grant
flappy burns it looks like this thing
but [ __ ] pooping or something you got
this baby I believe in you [ __ ] Betty
bear yeah beer ok where do I go um still
loser
you're not a loser bro share your bacon
loads this guy's goin [ __ ] nuts it's
really cool this animation that we need
to move it it like bleeds out cuz I've
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] link bro okay
sans Azad up baby
you think it through the bathroom and
quick go then the IG network tap tap tap
tap tap
yeah P games I'm doing this yes we're
doing this
it's so sick
[Music]
whoa stop what you are doing
empty Curtis Kimber ever I want to be a
ninja fox run on walls like a ninja
oh sure first draw your enemies like a
ninja compete with your friends
[Music]
get ready how good can I be I'm flopping
like crazy flopping all the way baby man
I really gotta [ __ ] piss [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hit my head on the ground okay I
can [ __ ] sucked
I play your dumb game thanks for the
eggs baby as Facebook trained yeah yeah
flappy bird yeah it's kind of dumb yeah
okay when it becomes a game kind of
summer the simple game ever thank you
might I interest you in Elena's update
the game has a competitive mode just
going to change your listless little
world what the [ __ ]
that wasn't even that game just [ __ ]
Texas
[Music]
you frag now baby you [ __ ] now
yeah not just a casual gamer whoa whoa
whoa labels are for losers we're all
gamers here it's cause we're all about
you know how it is baby okay that's it
that's cool let's go baby let's go come
on
come on Teddy just send the [ __ ] link
that's fine suddenly keep talking okay
all right yeah easy-peasy send it over
[ __ ] okay okay it's true this [ __ ]
like bro what the [ __ ] play your mind so
hard at this give me your prints on them
man [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] is this no [ __ ] out
of here I love jumping and shooting
okay [ __ ] I'm trying to [ __ ] do this
[Music]
drawing it you can collect eggs one in
who just answer a few questions
my name is Jonah okay a chick [ __ ]
like for like a meal it's really like
three hours like pretty big though I
snuck a lot as a kid and I don't drink
I'd like to protect my body you put your
seat on the car I never want to be a
ninja
[Music]
music [ __ ] hire something it's
everything
aw
DQ g a8 of UD g DQ GA
[Music]
hey there that guys get this video teddy
where as a challenge are i j FD r rj f
dr for rj f dr for [ __ ] is up with this
guy [ __ ] sucks
okay swear to videos do 495 for some
reason I don't remember deleting
anything to avoid this from ever
happening again I will be backing up my
videos okay plan the door is locked and
I can't find the key how do you can't
hidden cash
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
get ready I promise you're going to be
full of beans
after you're done six day yeah I'd be
that bad Sam okay 21 eggs [ __ ] beat
his ass now get the [ __ ] outta here
[ __ ] you up I get my gratifications
elsewhere like pornhub okay can you not
change the subject can you not put me
down this [ __ ] guy it wouldn't be a
month anything look at me I'm the best
I'm a loser actually er [ __ ] was
excited to beat your score yeah why some
email [ __ ]
this hasn't lost cause I'm gonna say his
right now he's a lost cause he got I got
this brothers
[Music]
he's getting into your head bro like we
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here hey I was
going on we see what I said she likes
buy anything agent and he tell you hey
we're almost what its gonna beat that
[ __ ] what the hell he get me still for
me it's all gone big house yeah yeah
if I could sack count that [ __ ] I
burned it
I'd like you don't said it's just it was
too easy
oh you got me
[Music]
of course not like [ __ ]
[Music]
how could you you are my friend Bobby
bird out hang up
that's guy why does it game mean so much
to you sublime it's my purpose I don't
know what's up [ __ ]
can we see well did you link what's
dizzy like that okay
[Music]
that's a bad bruh I'm gonna knock this
[ __ ] out okay t 5h t YJ t 5h t YJ think
it's alright yes stupid [ __ ] my name is
Teddy Jones I have been experiencing
blackouts recently I really want to see
what you think is a reflection of his
glasses losing huge chunks of time
usually triggered this when I tried to
leave the house really good job hiding
the camera filling him oh you could see
the softbox
it's all part right there that all
square I'm at home thank you there's
obviously window where there's a saw
what happened before lighting and I'm
recording this so that if I discover
anything new sure that you can be
painful perhaps you can't just can't
comprehend it what losing something with
a charmed life and all I'll stop playing
if you want pip and let me win is stupid
[ __ ] forget it I don't want your empty
polluted where it's that completely you
know steep it block
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] away from me
matchmaking
everyone please message me here can path
the path supervision he my phone's of
ours my tech keep changing very strange
I think there's a new code in here this
so every so often there is bolding words
when decay
[Music]
[Music]
with six
Wow they [ __ ] ripped you a new one
okay dating I think I [ __ ] out now top
dog again
yes stupid fetch
and what the [ __ ] I didn't say that
batch
what I say I said though why bother
chance at working and supporting do you
know what I use yeah urinary tract
infection so [ __ ] changing the subject
huh jumping and shooting urinary tract
infection it's the most my life it feels
like they're tiny needles poking your
insides and when you pee real bad you
need to [ __ ] hand trickles and drips
down that's how I feel right now about
everyone that's crazy tough you're a
[ __ ] psychopath mr. teddy
yeah this guy's going [ __ ] nuts again
this obsession churning yeah dad do you
gotta get like no go get like a [ __ ]
hour see car or something like when
there's like Zipcar things from
RadioShack like more things adding time
ago free time tough luck
I got the old version man new version
they [ __ ] you up
here's how we survive holy [ __ ] did
that's just escapism [ __ ]
[Music]
so this guy got so basically banned from
[ __ ] playing a defense of the age of
ancients - Toma - now he goes the [ __ ]
haircalf a [ __ ] ton of money let's get
[ __ ] addicted this guy is just like
obviously [ __ ] some she's gonna say
the meanest thing he got banned for for
five pretty key word up to the phone
okay mister at lunch unless he has no
games
[Music]
what's God
[Music]
okay this guy is actually like thinks
his brother's a game of the shoulder no
this guy is [ __ ] addicted
he's [ __ ] addicted that feeling when
you're supposed to be a queen we need to
see 4x
peanuts dang he's [ __ ] crazy today hey
God hey H capital v ck three let's do
this match make a shirt down this is
very important it all started when I
downloaded that game I played it for a
couple of hours but it feels like it's
been days I find text messages of me
sharing the game to my friends I don't
remember doing any of that it feels like
I've been chatting to other people but
[Music]
[Music]
this is jets stranger the whole [ __ ]
thing
[Music]
I'm gonna revive right here you really
need to get your nanny eggs okay I am
the egg they are free hope you have all
your eggs in your basket mister man
there's no [ __ ] way to get past it
[Music]
and you'll be gloriously rooted
oh [ __ ] let's beat this [ __ ] once and
for all
I [ __ ] dead it is so [ __ ] you should
be ashamed of yourself
[ __ ] die at level 2 it's a weak sauce
ok um d KJ h 2 v d KJ aged
[Music]
- [ __ ] wait [ __ ] crazy that's a
capital J hey that the capitalization
matters it's really annoying I mean I in
real life like a game - yeah right
you're really tons of games some of them
I enjoy
despite over here too much time on that
I should this game it just wants me to
keep playing
[Music]
I don't feel hungry or thirsty I don't
feel sleepy
I just I just kept playing I can't seem
to get out of this time to make up
you're saying with the figure that man
is so what the [ __ ] now the high silence
just keep playing okay
[Music]
ah yeah step at bats endings breed joy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you got him I can't all them
[ __ ] weird doesn't explain what she's
a groupie just a [ __ ] worried out
keep suckin a man second him in find a
friend bro
you [ __ ] sucks
okay you were a breath yes stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the same one that we've seen
like a hundred times
[Music]
[Music]
I'm flattered bro [ __ ] ads every two
seconds I'm gonna beat you
okay I hope you got [ __ ] unlimited
texting cuz he just like looks at me
like to where it has a sensor my brown
sweat
it's that black brown see I throw the
[ __ ] found out you know just throw in
the [ __ ] hard you can help you how's
that bollocks
what the [ __ ] changing the subject they
hate when I say that argue progress
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
nothing feels real
[Music]
eighty
I'm a gf
[Music]
[Music]
v9 in my house the clock of my phone
okay it's fun but you know before we get
into this menage-a-trois we'll end it
here I hope you all had a good morning
guys I hope y'all had a good one see you
on the next episode I okay guys I'm back
in between the episodes it's probably
been I don't know [ __ ] an hour maybe
it's for you guys I don't [ __ ] out I
just hit the stop on [ __ ] OBS and
walked away and I could hear the [ __ ]
chat going up on and on and I come back
on the [ __ ] 84 messages so I have not
looked at them yet
we'll see oh [ __ ] okay still groping
dark wait what
so Teddy's [ __ ] talking a bunch of
teddys are talking to each other and
he's like [ __ ] threaten each other
break each other's fingers real person
they're going they're going the [ __ ] is
going on here a woman left toss the
tosser your friends are picks up on the
screen you spent so much your life hours
what the [ __ ] okay Teddy kicked Eddie
from the group okay [ __ ] that scared me
I was like whoa what the [ __ ] why can I
like move okay Jesus I'm chucking jump
there yeah Briana bro
[Music]
that was a dead bro he's texting me one
last chance to redeem myself by the way
about now
I'm the true champion and it is like a
trick and just like pick somebody some
unresolved issues with your little
friend don't be a dark bush sorry joy
take my offer and go crazy
this is the best way to do a brown
yeah thank you
[Music]
stay late for your breath you're [ __ ]
you never cared that about me that's got
ready you stupid [ __ ] yeah I can't
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that nice
[Music]
the [ __ ] the game like disintegrating
[Music]
just a loud bat enjoying something like
[ __ ] something very much
yes step that [ __ ] yeah
so Teddy's melting
the whole [ __ ] phone is that growling
good rats
I happen to have it that he was the one
with the game he's back with the back
with the flappy yeah yeah yeah I got
that
he's gonna have to wind out he's got no
choice it's like he's gonna become the
real flappy bird wait what the [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] like melting okay
yes stupid [ __ ] so many eggs how many
[ __ ] eggs so he becomes an
advertisement
Teddy's worrisome reality while you were
spared units how allowed you and 54% of
players allowed Teddy to be consumed to
spare yeah he was horrible you
individual percent players but less than
half your life on a CSU and with 40% of
Clara photo against pay to win and flop
mr. Lee you have been person to not
share flaw he burbs all your contacts
like that and then your big-time person
applying objectives with you oh I gave
up when you're faded shut down you help
see watch you intended
Wow that's fun
it was shorting the other one is very
different
again this is fun I get pie make a
[ __ ] ton of these like it's been off
so these may be amazing
I like that they it was same but
different
they didn't also reuse anywhere I'm like
first I'm glad but I'm glad you have to
do that decoder puzzle anymore
also there's no corruption it was like a
long drawn-out thing and like I also had
a whole bunch of people like again
there's a big contact list and you could
go around it this time alright yeah